reculer pour mieux sauter jean castex
doit tout de même tranchée une décision
plus difficile qu'il n'y paraît exigeant
des garanties le premier ministre a
rappelé avoir prorogé jusqu'au 2 avril
l'agrément d'anticorps qui expirait
originellement au 15 février le temps je
cite de recevoir les réponses aux
questions complémentaires posés par le
gouvernement
version officielle des faits mais en
réalité le problème se pose ailleurs et
le grand paradoxe c'est que le
renouvellement de l'agrément c'est une
décision qui appartient au gouvernement
alors que un certain nombre de membres
du gouvernement ou de proches du pouvoir
sont concernés par nos actions donc jean
castex va de vraiment devoir faire
preuve d'une loyauté républicaine pour
renouveler cet agrément et je pense
qu'il y à des tensions qu'il ya des
appels pour ne pas dire qu'on ne pas le
renouveler
je pense que de diverses personnes qui
sont dérangés par nos actions ou qui
pourraient être dérangé par nos actions
un homme en particulier représente cette
fameuse tension donc par le vice
président de l'association eric dupond
moretti
anticor a porté plainte contre le
ministre pour prise illégale d'intérêts
dans une autre affaire
le garde des sceaux ne pouvait donc plus
examinées l'instruction de l'agrément
d'anticorps par les services de son
ministère sans risquer le conflit
d'intérêts juridiquement le gouvernement
n'avait pas le choix
conformément à la réglementation li
ministre estimant se trouver en
situation de conflit d'intérêts en
réfère au premier ministre un décret
venant par la suite précisé les
attributions que matignon exercera à la
place du ministre concerné pendant la
durée de ses fonctions
conséquence pour que cette demande soit
traitée de manière impartiale la
décision en est revenu à matignon en
revanche le service chargé d'instruire
la demande d'agrément appartient lui à
la direction de l'action criminelles et
des grâces un département du ministère
de la justice
placée sous l'autorité du garde des
sceaux lui même un lien de subordination
qui pose question
le fait que la direction des affaires
criminelles et des grâces relève de
l'administration du ministère de la
justice ne peut que nous
des interrogations sur l'impartialité de
la procédure le dossier aurait pu être
confiée à la direction des affaires
juridiques auprès du cabinet du premier
ministre
pendu à cette décision pour pouvoir
poursuivre son travail
anticor qui a relancé les affaires
richard ferrand et alexis kohler
notamment doit également faire face à
une crise interne de gouvernance depuis
le renouvellement de son conseil
d'administration en mars 2020 une
période compliquée et une attente qui
pourrait se prolonger pour l'association
à moins que jean castex ne fassent
preuve de loyauté république